professional fighter now and making a
small fortune in property how old are
you I'm 22 years old how many deals a
month can you sell last month I sold
nine Devils I'm Cushing business and I'm
also coaching fighting and training so
hard I'm doing both it gives me an edge
just feels good to have a side quest
sometimes I knew when I was working as
an engineer but I was always making
somebody else which that was not sitting
well with me at all I think that's why
you're so successful I think it's the
not just the business development but
the personal development what does your
business turn over a month last month in
August I turned over 45k so I got to
pinch myself because it's astounding
really
[Music]
so you're dominating leads at the moment
that's right young guy professional
fighter now yeah nice mate just went pro
this year I'll turn 12 yes I've been
getting paid for Thai boxing now very
cool mate very cool and making a small
fortune in property that's right yeah
how old are you I'm 22 years old 22
years old you achieved it a lot mate
what what are your parents like are you
from like a very successful family tree
honestly no so it's literally only me
doing this right now so I come from very
very humble beginnings early just screw
up with my grandparents all my entire
life bear Traders we just have news
agents ever since I was young
um in school so if we go back to high
school I was a little bit naughty and um
I never really I never really cared for
school you know I always knew but it was
a lot in me to be successful build well
when did you drop out of school
so I got suspended from school I just
knew you were dropped out or something
you got suspended I got suspended in
school yeah yeah hello how old were you
16 16 so I still start my exams
basically scared to bare minimum what
did you what what did you used to do at
school what you say you messed around a
bit naughty like what did you do you
know just uh I was more above about you
know speaking to friends and yeah you
know you just didn't pay attention to
pay attention to school yeah I was more
above about just chilling out having fun
when did you come across the world of
wealth when did you realize that school
doesn't teach Jack about
financial literacy or becoming a
business owner an investor interest
rates passive income active income
assets liabilities knowing when did you
discover that world and how did it
happen so this is really funny so back
in school I used to watch like American
Property like Chris cabron Ben guys and
I just realized there was nothing to do
with UK property so I've actually been
watching you since 2018 Samuel so you
were literally like 16 17 17 yeah yeah I
always find it awkward to get messages
from people and they're like I'm 16 I'm
17 and they're not an adult I'm 16 or
worse is 15. what advice would you give
me and I'm thinking I can't give you any
advice like because if I say to you
well drop out of school and do what I
did like I'm gonna have your parents
come in for me like I can't really
communicating with a kid it's weird yeah
so you were watching like Grant Cardone
and these guys from America and that
kind of opened your eyes up an open
mouth to invest in making money making
your money work for you you know I was
17 I think it's the same style many
people who start making money you know
I've enriched up Harder by Robert
Kiyosaki I developed reading books
self-improvement books thinking garbage
you know about Napoleon hillbulls books
really helped me yeah you know dream big
and um you know watch good shape success
that's great and and what about boxing
when did or sorry Thai boxing when did
that start Thai boxing start when I was
17 as well yeah yeah so I started quite
late into my adult life yeah but um I'll
just go passion for it yeah and uh quite
quickly I was competing you know doing
you know competitive spas and fighting
um and yeah I've just been on the ball
ever since how often do you train boxing
manner trained five times a week six
times a week and for an hour double
sessions hours on end so you do about
what 10 hours would you say training
probably man yeah on top of that you do
running and cardio or strength and
conditions on top of that is it deities
as well yeah serious yeah yeah
competitive as well yeah I'm fighting at
good level now so is that making decent
money yet or is it a bit of a slogan
it's a slow game a Thai boxing yeah it's
a slow game pop is where I make my money
yes winner yeah why do you do the boxing
if you're making so much money in
property
and this is a question I get asked
people say
well even now now I'm doing a bit of
boxing people like why or if you're
making so much money from property why
are you training people why have you got
a podcast what what it's like because it
just feels good to have a side quest
sometimes yeah you know doing different
things opening a Bank building a
hospital building schools setting up
pims
having a training company
then building a statue after me after I
die just feels good yeah but what about
you why do you Thai boxing I'm still
well it's simple really I'm still young
and I've got to drive I've got the
passion for it I know I'm good at it so
why did I just test myself and say how
far I can merely go with it do you ever
get conflicted though between your your
sports and your business do you ever
feel like because I I can't lie when I
was training for my big fight with Rob
Moore it was so difficult because I'm a
bit of an All or Nothing kind of guy as
well yeah so like
now I'm still training boxing but just a
bit lighter but like the amount of
training you're doing like proper
professional Thai boxing but then also
building a property business yeah how do
you like switch between the two
literally it just comes to it's hard to
switch off because I feel like as an
entrepreneur I'm working 24 7 sometimes
so when I train it's the only time I can
get away from the business so it lets me
they stress you know it lets me focus on
something else pop manager into
something else
so exactly equilibrium really right I
get I do get that sometimes when I've
been in boxing training I mean obviously
I'm not trained like you but after a
session I feel quite
de-stressed refreshed and Alive yeah I
don't feel like going sometimes I'm like
oh man I'm knackered but then I know
once I get there and afterwards I feel I
feel great and it's like you're ready to
tackle some new problems as well you
know because if you can get punched in
my face or you can whack pads then you
know you're ready to it rejuvenates you
when was your last fight
three weeks ago now did you win yeah
I'll knock some out in what round four
pounds
so okay how do you think talk to me
about mentality right your young guy
you're 22. how does a 16 17 year old kid
that's been suspended from school that
basically flunked out living with
grandparents no one around you at all
that sort of showing you the way to be
great success in in the traditional
sense like
how how do you from that environment
living in Leeds in just a few short
years to being a professional fighter
and having a property business that
makes what what does your business turn
over a month
last month in August I turned over 45k
right
none of the other Fighters that you're
fighting are making that kind of money
how does it feel as well when you're
fighting do you ever think about when
you're looking around all the fighters
everyone trains you everything like wow
I'm probably making more than all of
them to combined I don't want to be a
dick or anything but I don't want to be
a dick no of course not but does it feel
weird it feels good in the back of my
mind it just gives me that edge as well
yeah it does it really does why does it
give you an edge well because I'm
Cushing business and I'm also Cushing
fighting and training so hard so I'm
doing both yeah it gives me an edge
going back to my original question how
do you go from where you were some kid
in Leeds
to where you are like how does that
happen
you know what Samuel I still got to
pinch myself because it's you know it's
astounding really I don't even know how
I've done it just having the right
people around me just being confident in
myself you've got to be really confident
in yourself and you've just got to dream
big and take Massive Action all the time
what's harder
becoming financially free in property or
becoming a pro fighter
for both very hard on their own property
business is different you're going to
get a lot of rejections but I think
anyone can make it Thai boxing is
different because you're gonna get a lot
of setbacks injuries you know you're
gonna get some bad days but if you keep
pushing you're still going to make it
but you've got to have that strong
mentality to actually make it in bath
yeah I mean after doing a bit of both I
would say that fighting is way harder I
mean I can become financially free again
in a week from scratch yeah I know I've
got the experience in the skills I see
people all the time within a matter of
weeks how long does it take you to
become financially free after deciding
right I'm going all in I'm on the
academy how long how long did it take
you so I joined the academy last July
and really my first size of a month
where I turned over five figures you
know and that were last Joan or Joan it
was June so about four months June three
months about three months ago yeah about
three months ago so it took you a while
to get your first deal no so my first
deal I got in November right so I've got
an alarm for amongst us being on the
academy so I got that deal it was good
it was making good money making about a
grand somewhere around there twelve
hundred eight hundreds whatever then for
another few months I got my second
puppet in April so it was a bit slow
yeah and then all of a sudden it just
picked up and blew why do you think that
was
I feel like it's just as long as you
keep taking massive action it's gonna
happen for you so you really blew up
there around sort of June time yeah so
just before your big fight with me
because you were you were fighting on
the undercard about Marvin the card yeah
yeah yeah so around about then is when
it blew up what caused that
I think it was just constantly taking
action you know constantly getting my
face out there speaking to other Academy
members okay so brat was it was it your
brand brand did the boxing help it must
have helped a little bit also when you
started out how much money did you have
to get started in your property business
and where did that come from your good
question so when I was watching YouTube
videos when I was 17 you know watching
you I'd watch like things about stocks
so I started just funning as much money
as I could into stocks for my job from
your job what was your job I was a
maintenance engineer so as an apprentice
so I left school you know I got a
apprenticeship in maintenance
engineering were you earning good money
doing that or was it just like there's
an apprentice I was earning about 20 20K
okay but then I left about and got a
full-time job and I was learning I was
earning about 45k that again that's
pretty remarkable for Harold 18. so I
was 21. okay when I was earning 45. all
right it's still pretty good though so
you were basically just using that money
oh seriously all about money put it in a
bit into stocks yeah if that was going
up I pulled some money out paid for the
Academy I even property training back in
2020 as well which wasn't with yourself
good yeah I mean look man people
sometimes say to me you know oh I've
done of course somebody else's if I'm
going to be like oh no we're the best
come to us I'm like now man just get
educated whether that's from school
whether that's from Grant Cardone
whether that's from Tony Robbins and get
educated in in business and and real
estate I think property is probably in
my opinion I think it's probably the
strongest and safest investment I agree
why did you choose them because you've
dabbled around in other courses you did
a bit of stocks
why did you choose property I chose
property because I always knew if I
wanted my own business and to be
financially fit and to work for myself
because I knew when I was working as an
engineer I was always making somebody
else rich and for me that was not
sitting well with me at all I felt like
a slave having to clock in you know I
wasn't allowed Freedom yeah yeah you
know my income was capped sure and for
somebody that does bad in school and
doesn't necessarily like being under
Authority and being told what to do and
which I assume that probably is like yo
because you were messed around in school
and didn't want to submit to the rules I
I saw people aren't made for a job and
and those people often get ignored in
schools because if you're the kind of
kid that doesn't like doing it doesn't
want to think Inside the Box put your
hand up when you want to go to the
toilet wait for the Bell to ring yes
Miss yes if you're not about conforming
like that and some people are and some
people aren't but if you're not about
that life
then there's nothing really that they
teach you at school that's very helpful
they teach you about being a business
owner or an entrepreneur there's nothing
nothing no so thank God for YouTube what
a brilliant brilliant asset to humanity
YouTube and podcasts really are 100 you
know books as well you know
self-education it's also important did
you have a car at the time uh when I was
18 yeah did you turn your car into a
mini University and get like all the
audio books and stuff of course you did
man and I think that's what's paid off
for you I think that's why you're so
successful I think it's the not just the
business development but the personal
development
through all these books and readings
talk to me about the academy then so you
enrolled them to Academy about a year or
so ago yeah just offer yeah and what
were your thoughts at the time were you
a bit scared were you nervous
apprehensive big investment for a young
guy I was nervous but I knew I could
make it work and I just knew if I you
know submerged myself into it and really
got into it into a Nitty Gritty took
Massive Action but it will pay off for
me because of a network was so powerful
I was seeing people around me making you
know 20 30 40 50 60k a month which you
know they're genuinely people's salaries
you know in a year that's a that's a
yearly salary for a lot of people
um but I knew that I could always
achieve it and being around these people
I knew that it was going to be me it was
just a waiting game where do you think
that belief comes from do you think the
belief's always been there from school
or do you think it helped actually
seeing real people and like oh my gosh
they know better than me and like where
did the would you think that that
confidence and belief that you could
make that kind of he came from a little
bit above so it came from school because
I knew it was attainable you know and
you know what a little bit about my
advice I want to give back to my
grandparents as well you know I've lived
with my grandparents since I was young I
touched on this earlier so when I was
young my mum actually passed away sorry
to hear that bro yeah no it's all good
so I lived with my grandparents all my
life and you know then betrayed there
just got a star you know a news agent so
I just really want to give back to my
grandparents now yeah for sure then but
you know I can support them and provide
for them and you know help them out so
that's a big reason a part of my why as
well that's awesome so what do you spend
most of your time doing that on the
property business where's most of your
time
definitely deal saucing okay how many
deals a month do you sell last month I
sold nine deals damn yeah and how much
you charging for a finder
so last month if you did about 27 Grand
you know what I love about deal selling
the expenses and overheads are so low
because
I mean you've not even got any staff you
don't have an office you work from home
that's right yeah you don't have an
office you have any staff
27 Grand from deal selling and you've
got how many rent events do you have so
my element since I've got three I'm
picking up my fourth one this month as
well and in my management company I've
now got six so in total you've got like
nine properties that you're sort of
either involved with in some way
controlling managing what's the cash
flow on those for you so my elements
events big profit around 1K each you
know some months are better when my pop
is profit 1800 last month nice so you're
financially free just from your few rent
to rent yeah what about the management
stuff the Management's going really well
um world's view pop is turned over 10K
last month great I'll take my out of
that I paid myself on 2K from that cool
charging a 15 management fee also if you
had to list them in order of best to
worst managing other people's properties
deal selling or your own personal renter
rents what are you saying from best to
worst
that's it deal sourcing is up there at
the top yeah because it's high ticket at
the end of the day yeah I saw a high
ticket and uh it's nice to talk about
cash in my bank managing other papers is
really good as well because it's none of
my own money in yeah you're not there's
no risk for you yeah and then rent to
its last I'd say events last but it's
probably giant seconds okay interesting
though I love the management side of
things though so talk to me about that
how are you finding these properties
these opportunities to manage other
people's properties so how does it work
how much do you charge yeah so I
basically got a few landlords and estate
agents and I found now because I've been
doing property for around a year the
landlords I work with they're generally
passing my name onto other landlords so
quite a few of my properties recently
I've noticed it's been through words of
mouth because then you know I've been
off ipf event on time a couple of
maintenance issues I don't give them a
headache so passive maybe as properties
which I can then package and sell or
take on for myself and then say to the
investor look best pop is in Leeds you
might be in I don't know Manchester or
London or Scarborough I'll manage it for
you what do you think and um because
it's fully hands off and passive they
have all in for it and I charge around
15 15 and are you targeting people that
are already running at a service
accommodation themselves or you pitching
people and going hey why don't you run
this short stay let's I'll take over the
process you'll get more money I'll
manage it how are you doing that a bit
of bath so it's people who've never done
it before who I've got to educate at the
same time and people who are already
willing vet on service accommodations
and want to build their portfolio right
and you're just stepping in and managing
it exactly and providing a service
that's awesome what would you say what's
what's your experience been like on the
academy then like what's what's that
process been like
I've absolutely loved it you know you
know networked with so many people the
mentors you know yourself I mean you
always give me opportunity to go on
stage and talk which I thank you for as
well it's been amazing the network is so
valuable and being surrounded by so many
like-minded people you can't put a price
on it yeah it's see so no regrets no
regrets who was it that like you spoke
to about the academy initially or was
there someone you saw when it's on a
Wednesday or was there some sort of
thing that triggered you said I'm in or
what was it well I knew I wanted to pop
it for a while and I was actually
speaking to be on a phone call yeah
because I messaged you on Instagram and
I think I just messaged you saying I
want to pay for property training see
who got a bit to call me about the same
night and a few weeks later I got signed
up to event to rent essay and HMR
intensive makes sense got one of the
courses first see what happens yep and
when I was there in that environment I
just knew I wanted to be on the Academy
I wanted to go badge that's great man
what would you say has been the biggest
loan turning point over the last year or
so of being full-time well as I say
full-time property but you're also a
professional fighter full-time but being
financially free building a large
portfolio becoming a property
entrepreneur what would you say has been
some of the biggest learning points
which if you would advise to someone
that was a year or two behind you you'd
be like hey heads up boom reach out and
definitely utilize your network and for
mentors because they're going to help
you a lot you know if they have been
there so they can talk from experience
and they're going to help you see things
which originally you couldn't see makes
sense don't reinvent the wheel but you
send me boxing right imagine trying a
box or learn to fight without a coach
without any training just at home
reading books watching YouTube videos
you're never going to be any good you're
always going to be
when you get proper training and proper
education that's when you that's when
you Excel and yeah there's a bit of an
investment and yeah it's not going to be
riches overnight and yeah it's gonna
take a few months before you really
start seeing the investment and for some
people it might be I mean there's some
people that make money on the first
program they come on the program sell it
and for other people it's 6 12 months
later before they put it depends
everyone's different comparisons the
thief of Joy everyone's on their Journey
but I think um as I say you wouldn't try
and learn to box without a boxing coach
and I think it's finally the best
coaches for best mentors for best boxing
coaches who are really going to excel
your performance as well yeah so it's
like being on the academy and being
trained by the best you know yeah so I'm
going to ask some of the best
entrepreneurs yeah you're literally
there with Millionaires and
multi-millionaires like what about the
the accelerate coaching performance
program yeah like what happened
I got grilled yeah I got grilled yeah
but you got like myself Russell my
business partner Tony's did 100 male
whole bunch of millionaires sat down you
on the chair going right let's go
through your business where else can you
get that for like 20 minutes we were
just and we had to scrap off one of your
uh one of my Adventures yeah yeah yeah
because talk about that talk about that
so it was a furniture and sturgeon right
yeah so I was doing that and used this
analogy he said it's for Jordan Peterson
80 20 roll Tasha y'all spending 80 of
your time focusing on 20 of the money
because I might have turned over 20 25k
that month I only made four or five k
from the furniture and sturgeon and I
was spending hours getting both
properties set up and it was just not
sustainable I was killing myself so you
just told me you need to Outsource it
you need to do something about it
so that's what I've done I've took
action that's great and I've now focused
my 20 making eight percent of the money
but you're still sourcing and hopefully
that's helped scale you up a little bit
helps me I think you're right having the
right coach ironically I then tried to
pull you back in to help me do some flat
packing on one of my properties and you
were like no man I've been banned from
that now I'm not allowed to do that
back in
selling deals taking on properties
signing leases that's awesome well I'm
really really um proud of what you've
achieved and I know this is just the
beginning and on the on the on the
fighting side as well mate like huge
respect for that what will be your final
words of wisdom to anyone listening to
this final words of wisdom take Massive
Action believe in yourself get
surrounded in the right environment and
find the best coaches and mentors love
thanks branches